Chingy do here's a yellow Center kijiji
you're not in the vulgar jobs in your
car
kangaroo days hunter Cola will be a hit
would be actually in the South Korean
island province of Jeju there are female
divers known as hen you who have been
diving for hundreds of years
harvesting seafood to support their
families you do monkey muta wall
Eden Yoda sorry eh oh hey me hugging and
yes our people Hubble will be cuttin a
movie jeju-do you know and torment your
German booty double yolk side isn't an
Anglesey muda muda his whole photo so
check the loco moco's hanim gobble these
woman dive using no breathing equipment
holding their breath for minutes at a
time scanning the ocean floor for
valuable sea creatures but today is a
dying way of life the tendon Yong nee
Baga he needed a new Giri yes Horace
Hammond Enderman hanne-liebe England
techadon couldn't achieve woman payment
on Dale so - I'm not enduring memory
down inside I'm very - oh hey no honey
honey drops Annika Hailey and I dress up
at Google
karissa turnin an epod is king here
vaisya
Sybil
Leonardo's Hakata the as hi Donna
Chris oh yeah some happy couple
Paulo collectible inducing an oncogene
young to digital ha go it is alia
emissary ever felt upon personal touch
in River Candela she also bought
cappadocia by travelpod
brush and Oliphant a cappella chivalry a
human dose in dementia Rocco the veins
of you fall say he don't care that you
voltage enter pelvic le le by behaving
Oceano Talia recap evolutionarily plump
question about importante we see amo la
chica barbaric Ola la prima Barbara di
Milano edible various additional comme
un canta Dino's rlist ewa us our token
OC + tapa una volta chief and Schiavoni
Capelli wish the most important see if
actual a park in the cuando Villeneuve
A&E
the nori any recipe note on to the
whistles a tenth of an e have touch with
a be a una volta in baby rock or the
most important all right more to the
vessel is Barbie la knowledge is the Pew
we should to model the vessel lawful may
see a vagina fellow beanie Charlemagne
Ivaldi resume bravi
voyeuristic appealing no fatty
sorry Molly
to the north and west of Ireland's
county donegal is windswept Tory island
surrounded by the hungry waves of the
Atlantic
less than 200 people live here including
Ireland's last and only King a tradition
that goes back 1,400 years and my name
is Patsy dot Rodgers the King notorious
to say and you're very welcome to Tory
Island as king of the island Patsy's
role is mostly symbolic in the sixth
century a visiting saint created the
role in order to unify the Islanders in
defense of pirates but Patsy is very
proud of his islands rich heritage we
have our own Gaelic language everyone
speaks Gaelic on the island we have a
very strong culture we are session errs
Patsy's duties as king or few but he
takes his role as Island ambassador very
seriously
he becomes from various parts of the
world from a number of countries to meet
me under see me on the island and to
talk to me
when I accepted that simple honor of the
king I thought it would never come to
what it did come to now it's quite
serious now of the roughly 150 people
who live on Tory Island many are over 65
years old and the island struggles for
tourism and help from the mainland I'm
over 70 many are over 70 and the
Islanders that go to really depend on
under that type of original as much as
we like to they would like to see the
population of the island growing and
also a few jobs to teenagers and the
island to start swinging again
what they ate is knowing Patsy may be
the only Irish King but his hope is that
he won't be the last revival when I'm on
my dying bed hopefully before that
somebody will come up and offer to eject
the honor of the king of the Attic yes
Tony go
ah I'm tell you I feel sorry if I had to
retire you know why I have some many
customers I see Alex you never retired
yes they do what they have to retire
my name is Ali Alex Carozza and I fix
accordion since 1960 in New York the
people comes from all over the world to
fix the choreo because they say that I'm
the best I don't know
this some time brakes you have to change
very difficult I'm the only one in New
York to fix the choreo in this moment
you know see I fix the accordion and I
do the costume because I fix the
accordion correctly only I have this one
for the simple take a look this is a
very old forest whoa
at least this according 75 years old how
old are you hi if I tell you you won't
believe it
I'm 88 you believe it that's right
Howard is him if I tell you 93 you won't
believe it
we working together 60 years since 1949
let yesterday yeah Jim looks like a
jester
you can understand an instrument is like
some part of your life you care for the
instrument more than anything else I
love this more than anything else it's
not the morning sometime in life if
you're healthy and happy
money doesn't count this is what I
believe maybe I'm wrong but now you have
all my secret good
de nada okay
Sudan nah Jean Fatou these are the last
three northern white rhinos left in the
world they're here at old pajetta
Conservancy in Kenya efforts by the
staff and veterinarians are the last
chance to keep these rhinos from going
extinct completely my name is dr.
Stephen guna Iowa cattle kinetic
insolvency as the wildlife veterinarian
poachers have been the main cause of the
loss of this subspecies there's huge
demand for rhino horn and Rhino products
if there wasn't demand for rhino horn I
wouldn't be poaching like the war
against terrorism it's a very dangerous
kind of situation
the northern white rhinos were brought
to the Conservancy in 2009 from a zoo in
the Czech Republic even though they live
on the Conservancy they're still at risk
from poachers to keep the Rhinos safe
they're watched around the clock my name
is Zachary muta I work for and pajetta
Conservancy is not my trainer at keeper
I do love ultra wild animals but my
favorite one is all right now it's my
passion I know when they are happy when
they are nervous and everything Sudan is
the last male of the northern white
rhino yeah it's my favorite friend is
the most gentle the keepers are keenly
aware that the rhinos have been brought
here to live out their last days so far
breeding efforts have been unsuccessful
and though the chances are slim around
30% the last hope they have is to try in
vitro fertilization if IVF succeed then
they will not get extinct we might be
lacking we might be unsuccessful but we
are trying all means to see if we can
save them